Resident Evil 7 is capcom’s attempt to make
its beloved horror franchise scary again,
by taking the series original formula of claustrophobic
locations and limited ammo and mixing it with
newer horror concepts like first person cat
and mouse chases.
This first person perspective also allows
for a new way to play, Virtual Reality.
Resident Evil 7 is a big deal for VR because
unlike Batman Arkham VR or whatever that Final
Fantasy XV thing is, this isn't a short experience.
RE7 is a big budget AAA numbered sequel.
So I saw a golden opportunity by playing the
entirety of RE7 in PSVR.
The whole thing.
Which means experiencing moments like this.
And this.
The game does a good job offering several
adjustable options in VR like Field of View,
walking speed, and crouch.
The big thing is camera rotation options but
I’ll admit that none of them are perfect.
On the default setting, the camera snaps at
angles of 30, 45, and 90 degrees.
This is the safest option if you want to minimize
the risk of motion sickness but the jerky
nature of it took me out of the experience.
The option I used is called smoothing and
while I felt a little sick at first I was
able to get used to it and play the whole
game this way.
I would seriously advise caution though when
trying this setting and if you're prone to
motion sickness, I would avoid it all together.
Issues like this are partially due to the
fact that Resident Evil 7 isn’t designed
to be VR only, it has to work as a traditional
game too.
That means no use of Playstation Move controllers
to simulate your hands.
The most you get is the camera is now controlled
by your head.
So Resident Evil’s Virtual Reality is less
about enhancing the gameplay experience and
more about immersing you in its environments.
The true strength of playing something in
VR is the sense of presence you gain.
You are more aware of what's around you and
what's behind you.
You can tell how long a hallway is and how
close an enemy is with greater accuracy.
You really feel like you are walking around
this mansion.
And Resident Evil 7 is the perfect game for
this because its environmental design and
art are top notch.
The realistic art style fits perfectly.
Every room is full of notes to read, pictures
to look at, and the disgusting imagery, my
god it's almost to gross to look at sometimes.
This game is gnarly and fantastically disgusting
regardless of how you play it but being able
to see it so up close without that disconnect
between you and the TV makes your stomach
churn.
Now let's talk about everyone’s favorite
part, the scares.
There are plenty of those in your face jump
scares that will get you for sure, but for
me the memorable moments come from entering
a new location for the first time and just
having to walk through it.
You have no idea what's gonna happen next
and that is just the worst feeling.
I hated, and i mean hated the Old House.
Its dark, its rotting, and I seriously wanted
to take the headset off when the giant bugs
showed up.
We’d be here all day if I mentioned every
memorable moment but a few stand out scares
include; crawling inside this wall full of
centipedes.
Walking through neck high water, the entirety
of this location.
After beating the game I went back and played
outside of VR to see if there are any differences
and the answer is yes.
For one it's way easier in my opinion to shoot
in VR because you can aim with your head.
This might make the game slighter easier in
VR but I never found the difficulty balance
to be an issue when playing.
This also means if you freak out or try and
look away it messes up your shot which is
pretty neat.
Side Note: It is possible to use your added
camera moment from VR to slightly break the
illusion of some scenes.
It doesn’t ruin anything but it's pretty
funny.
Another thing is that a lot of character animations
are absent in VR.
Stuff like getting knocked down or jumped
by an enemy doesn’t happen.
This is most likely because taking camera
control away from you for even a moment would
induce motion sickness.
Having played it in VR first I never missed
these animations or noticed their absence,
but playing it again I was surprised how many
of them were taken out.
Of course sometimes the game can’t cut scripted
moments when they are story related.
So to avoid motion sickness the game jarringly
switches to you floating in a black void with
a screen playing a pre-rendered cutscene in
front of you.
It's the worst part of the VR experience in
that it quickly reminds you that you are playing
a video game.
Perhaps the strangest part of playing Resident
Evil 7 a second time without VR is that I
think playing in VR first actually kinda ruined
the game for me.
It’s like when you go back and look at vacation
photos.
It's the same thing, but everything is flat
now.
You aren’t there in the same way.
There's a real lack of punch to it.
Don’t get me wrong I still think Resident
Evil 7 is a great game but this is a weird
and slightly amusing issue that I think a
lot of people who play this in VR first will
experience.
You might also be wondering what it's like
to play a 9 hour game from start to finish
in VR?
Well I wouldn’t recommend playing it all
in one day like I did because at the end of
the night my eyes felt really awful after
having a screen stuck to them all day.
But other than that I felt fine.
You’d think I’d have wanted to take a
break to save my heart from all the tension
and scares but honestly I was enjoying the
game so much I just kept wanting to play it.
My first playthrough of Resident Evil 7 is
gonna stick with me as one of those memorable
gaming experiences partly due to playing it
VR.
Even if it's not a perfect example of how
the technology can reshape games as we know
them, getting to see the Baker Mansion for
the first time that way is something you only
get one chance at and if you have the opportunity
to experience it this way, I highly recommend
it.
By the way if you are interested in just watching
a bunch of people get scared playing Resident
Evil 7 in VR, there is a video where I threw
some GameSpot employees into a room for your
enjoyment.
And If you have played Resident Evil 7 in
VR or if you want to try it now let me know
in the comments.